six mois yacht d'abord comment va le
pilote j'ai pu lui parler et et j'ai eu
la chance de monter dans l'ambulance je
prouve qu il va bien il a une petite
blessure à la tête mais il est tout à
fait conscient et il n'a pu s'exprimer
normalement je suis surtout après un
accident comme ça qu'on peut comprendre
ce qui s'est passé ce matin mais je
n'étais pas dans l'avion et je n'ai vu
décoller
je pense qu'il a si vous la distance
qu'il a utilisée au décollage encore une
fois ce n'est pas de son fait
c'est dû à la position du nouveau
taxiway québec qui a été installée à
l'aéroport du réseau
la licence et il a utilisé des colts un
peu faible donc l'avion ne montait pas
donc dans un souci de sécurité il a
voulu faire demi tour par la gauche à
une altitude très basse et
quand il revenait vers la piste son aile
gauche a heurté un arbre heureusement
d'ailleurs ce qui l'a fait pivoter et je
suis guère permis de se retrouver dans
une position où il n'a pas explosé